die geschichte beginnt auf dem
schrottplatz in linz der perkussionist
christoph sitzen 27 jahre alt ist auf
der suche nach klang der österreichische
komponist georg friedrich haas hat ein
konzert für ihn geschrieben für
orchester und klangwerk und dieses
klangwerk soll eben kein handelsübliches
musikinstrument sein sondern altmetall
die mitarbeiter vom schrotthandel haben
spaß daran
[Musik]
das nehme ich mit glaube ich weil das
hat einfach einen unglaublichen bass wie
hat man sich das gesamte instrument
vorzustellen was wir zusammen suchst
naja es ist eben eine eine wand aus ja
am schluss wahrscheinlich an die 100
instrumente also instrumente schrott die
zu instrumenten werden und die werden
halt alle aufgehängt auf stativen und es
ist am schluss über zwei meter hoch und
drei meter breit
da muss ich rein
ich habe noch nicht eine ich habe schon
ein paar felgen mitgenommen und eine
familie ist auch tatsächlich ins
mercedes amg die klingt unglaublich das
ist wirklich wie eine wenig kirsten
block gefasst
seit zwei monaten sammelt er um ein
möglichst großes klangspektrum
zusammenzubekommen um auch melodien
spielen zu können
ich suche noch ein paar hohe und sehr
schnelle schafe also obertonreichen
klänge
das klingt alles nur show bin gespannt
wie daraus musik wird gute frage
das ist jetzt die ecke mit den spezial
sachen die liebe ich weil da sind immer
wieder ganz ganz unterschiedliche dinge
wie man jetzt einfach hier auch sie
pokale
okay der nicht hier ist 100
und jetzt muss er das ganze schwere zeug
irgendwie abtransportieren und in seinen
proberaum bringen ein großer proberaum
so ein perkussionist braucht platz
hier wird der shop sortiert ausprobiert
und musiziert so sieht die klang wand
aus und so klingt sie
[Musik]
ich bin vor allem gespannt wie sie es
mir mal gestern nicht weil das ist das
ist wirklich ein ganz wichtiger teil 1
diese verbindung im klang von die von
der klang wand dann auch mit dem mit dem
orchester ja unterbrechen über die
schrott geschichte kurz weil christoph
sitzen ja nicht nur schrott spielt
sondern percussion auf weltklasse niveau
gerade hat er eine cd aufgenommen mit
dem titel silence darauf interpretiert
er berühmte stücke der klassik auf der
marine
[Musik]
drei wochen später die philharmonie in
luxemburg hier findet am abend die
welturaufführung des konzerts mit der
klang wand statt hier wird der schrott
aus linz zu musik auch der komponist ist
angereist um zu schauen ob auch alles
gut läuft mit seinem außergewöhnlichen
werk georg friedrich haas wir haben eine
frage herr haas wie kamen sie denn auf
diese idee warum musste es ausgerechnet
schrott sein
das ist nicht schuld das sind wunderbare
klangelemente ich versuche eine musik zu
schreiben die auch ohne dass man
spezialist der musik ist über emotional
berühren kann und menschen erreichen
kann und nicht deswegen nicht obwohl sie
mal ist sondern weil und das ist das was
für mich das konzert überhaupt keine
musik auch auszeichnet also mich berührt
diese musik körperlich nicht nur
emotional sondern wirklich also die
emotion geht so weit dass ich das im
ganzen körper eben spüren kann
und dann endlich das konzert für klang
band und orchester
[Musik]
am schluss wechselt er von der klang
wand zu den normalen trommeln von der
klangsinnlichkeit zur puren nr
[Musik]
doch am anfang war der schrott
[Applaus]